They do not accept the rules of democracy,
do not recognize legitimacy to left-wing governments
and constantly call for transhubism.
You are the democratic anomaly.
El Pepe cannot be chosen as guardian,
Secretary of the Constitution,
among other things
because in 1978,
when the constitution was voted on Tuesday,
half of its deputies did not vote for it
for the PP.
Spain is always breaking with the
in,
with the zapatero government,
with the approval of the status,
with the motion of censure of Rajoy,
Rajoy for the formation of the government of progressives.
But the truth is that Spain is only at risk
to break when the PP governs,
that raises the temperature and generates conflicts
everywhere.
They talk about Concordia,
of equality,
while opposing any dialogue between the two countries.
between the state and the governor.
The PP can talk to Yus normally,
Right, Mr.
González Pons?
But if you make it add up,
then you are breaking Spain.
Aznar pardoned 15 members of Yura land,
and Rajoy,
with good judgment,
offered amnesty to lower the tension in Catalonia,
eh?
But when other forces talk about 1
amnesty,
El Pepe brings thousands of people to Madrid
shouting that Spain is going to be broken.
Pardon,
waiver of criminal action or amnesty
have been used in Spain and other countries
with absolute normality.
In fact,
in Portugal
1 amnesty for young people has just been approved
last July
for the pope's visit.
Amnesty is 1 institution
collection in international treaties
in force in Spain,
also contemplated by law,
yes sir,
in the Criminal Procedure Act.
It is 1 figure
in force in our domestic legal system
and has 1 limit,
has 1 limit.
It cannot be applied to prostitution offenses,
against humanity and war.
The objectives of the amnesties
in international law are
encouraging reconciliation
and help restore normal relationships
in the life of a country.
"Amnesty is always the end of 1 process.
"
of standardization,
and in this case
it WILL be
after 1 Major understanding agreement between the US
and the rest of the state.
And they cannot say that amnesty is not constitutional.
because it is not expressly mentioned in the constitution.
Evictions are not constitutional,
then,
layoffs,
maternity leave or scholarships
They are also not mentioned in the constitution.
The constitution does not prohibit amnesty,
is 1 legislative power
operating on 1 conduct,
while the pardon is the power of the executive branch
and operates on criminal convictions
and none of them affects the powers of the judiciary.
The Constitution does prohibit a general pardon,
which did not prevent the fact that in only 1 Council of Ministers
Mr.
Aznar approved
1,443 pardons.
The reason for this general pardon
man ended the millennium in a jubilee year,
1 arbitrary ground,
without any general interest
and unfit for 1 state to confessional.
If this quasi-general pardon
did not break the separation of Powers?
Why?
According to the PP,
1 amnesty would be 1 attack on the judiciary.
In our constitutional system
possession is prohibited
of conduct that may be committed
following the pardon,
amnesty?
Because amnesty does not decriminalize any conduct,
only 1 institution that applies exceptionally
to normalize
1 conflict situation.
And look,
the constituents of '78
addressed the issue of amnesty and concluded,
As far as amnesty is concerned,
they said,
Additionally,
it is agreed not to constitutionalize this issue.
It was decided not to limit it constitutionally,
something very different fromla
to let the boy board her
when necessary
in democracy.
In democracy,
which is not expressly prohibited
is susceptible to legislative development.
And the process of détente
and dialogue with the Catalan parties
carried out by the progressive government
is normalizing the situation in Catalonia
and in Spain
has brought us a decline in support for the ultra-right.
Maybe that's why
you do not want to relax the situation in Catalonia,
because the granting of exceptional measures
for hundreds of people
who participated in the October 1 referendum,
for example,
those in charge of educational centers
where the ballot boxes were installed,
is 1 simple e Paso
for standardization.
More serious events such as the military takeover of this confrontation,
the rejection of all deputies
and the entire government,
were pardoned in 1988
with the agreement of the Popular Party.
Popular Party governments gave 4 amnesties
by economic cuts,
Rajoy alone benefited more than 30,000 offenders
that avoided sentences of up to 5 years in prison,
among them Bárcenas,
the Franco or Diego Torres family.
Lord fixed,
do not oppose a new phase of meeting and dialogue.
between the Catalan society and that of the rest of Spain.
Its policies have been the factory of independence,
They have provoked social and political rejections.
When they govern.
Don't use tension and hate to get votes.
Be patriots,
work for Concord,
for dialogue and the territorial question
for not doing so and for its permanent double standards.
Therefore,
disregard for democracy
and workers.
You are not going to have the support of adding
nor from this camera
to be President of the Government of Spain.
Thank you very much